hallo blumen wir haben ein thema virus
der wahrheit hat das kommt von mir
wahnsinnig lustig was wir aus der krise
lernen können ich sehe ihren gesichtern
sie finden dass das zu früh ist und
jetzt schon darüber gedanken zu machen
was wir darüber lernen kann ich sage
ganz heute hat man virus nicht mit ja
genau und sehr witzig ich finde es aber
deshalb weil ich mich wahnsinnig ärgere
darüber dass wir überhaupt in dieser
situation sind denn es war eine
vermeidbare situation es gibt genug
leute hätten wir erst mal zu bevor sie
loslegen ja es gab genug leute übrigens
bill gates auch relativ bekannte leute
die gesagt haben das nächste mal das
weltweit millionen menschen sterben wird
nicht der große krieg sein sondern eine
große virus epidemie
wir haben vorläufer gehabt aus china mit
diesen lungenkrankheiten das heißt wir
wussten im prinzip was auf uns zukommen
kann
wir wissen dass wir in der
globalisierung solchen sachen total
ausgesetzt sind und jetzt merkt man dass
bestimmte gesundheitssysteme damit
einigermaßen besser zurecht kommen als
andere und man muss sich fragen warum
haben die sich nicht besser vorbereitet
warum ist nach der finanzkrise nach der
eurokrise die öffentliche infrastruktur
in vielen ländern total zusammen gespart
worden und die zahlen jetzt alle den
bitteren preis dafür
und deshalb haben wir lernen was er
lernen könnte es wieder mehr geld zu
investieren in das gesundheitssystem in
die öffentliche infrastruktur um uns
besser zu schützen vor solchen sachen
ist künftig auch kommen werden aber das
tut mir leid es tut mir echt leid aber
es ihnen das nicht zu doof dass er sich
jetzt wirklich gedacht so kommen jetzt
versuchen ihre der neoliberalismus hat
den startplatz gespart these am beispiel
von chor und das ist ja das war ich
schon exerzieren das sehen sie doch in
vielen ländern in den ländern der euro
krise in spanien und altar es heißt das
dann einfach sein systemisches versagen
gegenüber einem noch nie dagewesenen
verbreitungs schnellen virus ist jetzt
die der beleg dafür dass der
neoliberalismus die staaten
kaputtgemacht und tote voll ist es das
was sie sagen wollen dann sagen deswegen
neoliberalismus tötet hat der deb der
papst hat gesagt kapitalismus tötet ja
und jetzt können sie es hier jetzt
können sie richtig sehen natürlich tötet
kapitalismus amerika ist das reichste
land der welt und ist das was sozusagen
mit unfassbarer geschwindigkeit von
dieser new york ist am umgang mit hatte
kapitalismus kommt nicht mal mit dieser
art von krankheit jahre nicht hallo
kommt nicht damit klar dass er bei
einigen themen problem dann passieren
sie keine verbindung ich hatte das ist
hatten ich glaube es hat nicht so
liberalismus und es hat auch nichts mit
kapitalismus zu tun weil sie im
kapitalismus können sie eine
vollversorgung haben wie in deutschland
oder eben ein land haben wie die usa wo
ganz viele keine krankenversicherung
haben die jetzt wirklich in den hintern
elfen sind ja und natürlich gibt es
unterschiedliche ausstattungen mit
diesem jetzt ein bisschen technisch
intensivbetten und beatmungsgeräte ja
kann sein aber auch dass differiert ja
nicht entlang der kapitalistisch nicht
so kapitalistisches land sondern das
differiert allein entlang ist es ein
funktionierender staat oder eben nicht
im sinne von gut aufgestellt frankreich
zum beispiel eine total starker staat
und hat aber deutlich weniger von diesen
intensivbetten als deutschland ja dass
ihre these eiert hinten und vorn und
wenn es das ist was wir aus der krise
lernen können dann kann ich nur sagen es
ist echtes schäbige man echt verspätete
versuch noch mal wieder ins spiel zu
kommen über eine systemkritik das ist
doch lieber über die frage geben sie
sich so schnell weg von dem thema dann
lassen sie es dabei bleiben dass ein
funktionierender staat der sich um seine
leute kümmert ihr ein gesundheitssystem
vorhält was auch in der lage sein muss
mit dieser art von krankheit fertig zu
werden ist ein ganz kurz die wenigsten
gedanken bevor sie ins zerfetzen lassen
sie mich doch wenigstens einmal
ausbreiten das hier kommt doch nicht
überraschend wir hatten anfang der
nullerjahre gab es vorboten von solchen
sachen es gab leute die haben davor
gewarnt und zwar gesagt noch mal nicht
die dümmsten leute der welt haben davor
gewarnt
wir wissen dass wir in dieser
globalisierung eine eine ansteckende
krankheit wenn die dieser art ist sofort
weltweit haben das ist alles bekannt und
trotzdem kommen jetzt bestimmte
gesundheitssysteme deutlich schlechter
damit zurecht als andere was lernen sie
denn daraus was sagt ihnen das ist das
alles auch zufall
nichts hat mit nichts zu tun das waren
sie leer aus ich glaube es hat mit
politischen versagen zu tun aber nicht
mit wenn man so will systemischem
versagen sondern bestimmte länder und
angefangen mit china das irgendwie eine
mischung aus kapitalismus und diktatur
ist also das können sie als starken oder
schwachen start gar nicht buchen
aber es auf dieser skala nicht abtreten
sieben vergleichen hand damit zurecht
gekommen
da muss man auch mal sagen ja
und dann glücklich hält die ausbreitung
dieses virus weil sie 14 tage oder noch
länger weiß man nicht ganz genau geheim
gehalten haben dass sie überhaupt ein
problem haben und dann sind sie mit
ihren irgendwie die österreicher auch
den vertrag mit ihm verdankt österreich
europa die auswahl der bild zeitung so
gelobte kurz seitdem hat dann folgt der
hut sein der hat aus er beziehungsweise
in einem föderalen staat der
österreicher auch ist möglicherweise
auch ganz überwiegend um die
nachgelagerte ebene des landes also
dieser landesbezirk wieder heißen haben
als ihnen wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
start war um die schönen touristen und
das schöne den schönen umsatz als lift
haben sie viel zu spät zur quarantäne
gebiet erklärt volker bin ich vollkommen
dabei aber das alles trägt nicht auf die
systemische frage ein
ich glaube es geht um politik versagen
viele haben sich nicht getraut und
manche haben es geheim gehalten manche
hatten offenkundig nicht die melde
ketten und zwar unabhängig noch immer
von der frage ist es eine föderale
aufgestellte geschichte auch geschäfte
oder ein zentralisiertes land
rechtzeitig zu sehen was auf sie zurollt
und rechtzeitig maßnahmen zu ergreifen
ich glaube da die bundesrepublik bislang
zumindest scheint dann technisch gut
aufgestellt sein was die zahl der betten
angeht der krankenhäuser ärzte und b
halbwegs rechtzeitig reagiert zu haben
ist dass sie reden sehr viel weil ich
verstehe überhaupt nicht worauf sie
hinauswollen
die bertelsmann-stiftung also auch 1 1
fink sozusagen der der der der sehr
weitgehend auch diesen neoliberalen
umbau der gesellschaft immer
vorangetrieben hat hat noch vor unten
vor gar nicht so langer zeit gesagt das
krankenhaus systeme deutschland total
aufgebläht das muss alles runter gespart
werden und so man die studie werde mir
an deren stelle aber so was von peinlich
heute ganz gut und werden heute klagen
heißt ja dass äpfel und irgendwie das
ist das ist nicht fair dass wir sie auch
scheint es ist wirklich polemisch und
echt ich rede vor dem verlust
definierenden krankenhäusern
funktionierende krankenhäuser sind nicht
das problem ich glaube dass frankreich
genug funktionieren die krankenhäuser
und spanien auch was sie nicht haben ist
eine ausreichende zahl von
intensivbetten und beatmungsgeräte für
diese spitze
wir wollen diese große zahl von fällen
auf einmal ja und das glaube ich halte
das mir das problem sondern ich meine
mich zu erinnern
der kollege schon dass sie von der woche
sagte wieso denn flecken bekommen ist
doch quatsch dass sie doch alle einmal
durch infizieren und dann passt das
schaut sie sehen ja was in spanien
passiert ist die haben die kurve nicht
schnell genug flach gekriegt und jetzt
werden
ich bin hier nicht der hansi müller ja
und die hobbygeologen weil sie haben es
ja immer gesagt jeder muss selber gesagt
und worauf ich hinaus will ich glaube
nicht dass sie von der frage kann das
krankenhaus system dieser sehr
speziellen krankheit in einem sehr
kurzen zeitraum zurechtkommen jahren
einschließen können auf die frage haben
wir zu viele zu wenige krankenhäuser
das ist einfach nicht der fall sie haben
zu während sie versuchen dem thema
auszuweiten also meinen sie sollte es
auf sie wollen ist pauschalieren und auf
den start nahe sein will ich sagen dass
ich ständig ansteckende
lungenkrankheiten sind offensichtlich ja
ich bin da kein experte ich bin nur
journalist ich kann das immer nur lesern
recherchieren ansteckende
lungenkrankheiten sind offensichtlich
ein großes thema in der internationalen
gesundheitspolitik schon seit vielen
jahren und es gab bereits vorläufige
rede hier nicht von ebola wo die leute
sozusagen sterben bevor sie den virus
anstecken können krankheit die aber
deshalb den den weg um die welt nicht
angetreten hat diese lungenkrankheiten
tun ist aber und wir sind ganz
offensichtlich wir als als westliche
länder unzureichend darauf vorbereitet
und natürlich jetzt können sind 20 mal
sind einer sich jetzt einfach weg tun
sie können es doch ich glaube nicht dass
man das vorhalten kann das werden sie
genau die frage ich glaube eher dass sie
ein system haben müssen das schnell
genug aufbauen kann also das schnell
genug in der lage ist jetzt beraten uns
geräte zu produzieren meinetwegen aus
normalen betten intensivbetten zu machen
etc
das ist wird die leistungsfähigkeit
eines nationalen gesundheitssystem im
vergleich zum anderen nachweisen
und ich finde ich finde jetzt quasi
diese grundsätzlichkeit der
entschuldigung noch mal machen wir sagen
grundsätzlich ja aber das erinnert mich
an was anderes nämlich an die an die
bereitschaft alles infrage zu stellen
auch alles mit sich machen zu lassen als
bürger 95 prozent der bürger finden die
maßnahmen richtig und ich gebe zu ich
gehöre dazu ich finde die maßnahme über
alles betrachtet richtig und hoffe sehr
dass wir möglichst schnell wieder raus
kommen weil sonst haben wir letzte woche
hat die heimreise zu
total sind ja auch vollkommen disparates
gibt der vollkommen verschiedene maße
die die maßnahme zum beispiel die
grenzen zu schließen halte ich für
vollkommen unsinnig verstehe ich auch
ehrlich gesagt haben wir 90 haben leute
sind jetzt quasi auf einem pfad das
finde ich per se heikel und dann sind
wir nächstes jahr müssen wir nicht unser
wirtschaftssystem umstellen und dann
ziehen sie diesen diese gruppe von
leuten womöglich hinterher in der
aufwallung diesem moment haben also ich
finde wir haben einen relativ seltsames
meinungsklima im moment ich mach das
doch niemandem zum vorwurf
aber ja die bereitschaft aber mannheim
ist es dasselbe was lernen wir aus der
krise wie schnell sind die deutschen
bereit und andere länder natürlich auch
massive eingriffe in ihre bürgerlichen
freiheiten hinzunehmen
foto greater good für das bessere
wichtigere im moment wichtiger wie
gesundheits man wundert sich auch von so
genannten linken kommt dann auch
irgendwie ja
das dient doch nur unseren besten erst
dient ja nur der gesundheit steht die
anlage kommen ja aber dann nächstes mal
wenn wenn wenn man gesagt wird wir um
morde zu verhindern oder meinetwegen
sexuelle übergriffe auf kinder ist ja
aber auch notwendigen handydaten 17 was
wann werden oder keine ahnung also
praktisch in persönlichkeitsrechte
einzugreifen ganz schwierig wir haben
diese debatten in deutschland übrigens
sind wir da relativ vorsichtig und
langsam ganz im unterschied zu anderen
ländern ich finde es zum beispiel gut
dass wir anders als das robert koch
institut die möchten dass ja eigentlich
gern er diese epidemiologen das möchte
er natürlich den totalen zugriff haben
auf alles wollen am liebsten alles
kontrollieren da sagen ja die deutschen
datenschützer und die politik an den
stopp stopp stopp
so weit wollen sie war schon halb in die
wir haben gesetzentwurf du willst und
ist dann wieder rausgekommen aufdruck
also daran noch funktionär wenn das
funktionieren auch funktioniert die
politische debatte aber wenn ich meine
stelle sich vor die zahlen werden so
drastisch und die bilder werden so
drastisch wie in spanien oder frankreich
dann weiß ich aber nicht ganz genau was
sie noch mehr geschwemmt wird verstehen
sie und genau auf diese auf diese weise
wollen sie ja leute sind wenig müssen
den kapitalismus infrage zu stellen
ich finde man einen wollen die
bürgerfreiheiten wegnehmen
die bürger für rechts und der
bürgerfreiheiten wecken und sie wollen
das wirtschaftliche herz abschaffen ich
will den kapitalismus nicht abschaffen
aber ich finde beim thema hier woraus
was wir lernen können
zum beispiel habe ich jetzt gelesen in
vielen städten wo sehr viele airbnb
wohnungen angeboten werden sinken
plötzlich die mietpreise weil diese
ganzen rbi wohnungen nicht mehr an
touristen vermietet werden können also
gestellten stellen die leute sie dem
normalen mietmarkt zur verfügung um
überhaupt noch irgendeinem ort zu haben
und zack haben sind ganz viele wohnungen
plötzlich dauert die mieten sinken und
die sehr angespannte mit lage in den
zentren entspannt sich sein wurde das
wäre doch zum beispiel ein learning aus
dieser krise dass man so so so so
institutionen die airbnb die die
bestimmte märkte komplett verzerren und
irgendwas kaputt machen entweder
komplett verbietet oder sie ganz ganz
ganz ganz stark reguliert wie man ja in
paris ganz vorsichtig angefangen hat
also so perverse auswüchse auch dieses
systems auf die werden wir jetzt
aufmerksam gemacht durch die krise das
auch nicht so schlecht
also wenn erwin wie ein bisschen
eingeschränkt wird dagegen damit das
finde ich jetzt noch nicht die
abschaffung des kapitalismus
aber wenn man so der staat beteiligt
sich jetzt zum beispiel an firmen
möglicherweise ohne ende und dann haben
wir so eine staatswirtschaft etabliert
das lasse ich mir alles gefallen wenn es
zeitlich begrenzt und wenn es nur dazu
dient diese firmen über eine auf eine
sandbank von mangelndem flüssigen geld
sagen dass liquidität zu bringen okay
aber sie müssen es sprach war ja aber
sie müssen da auch wieder aussteigen
und sie haben in bebra der stadt euro
unter dem kiel
ja und eine handbreit hirn zwischen den
ohren wäre auch nicht schlecht und das
heißt das muss alles befristet werden
nicht gekommen diese komischen
ausgangssperre oder kontakt
einschränkungen sondern natürlich auch
die ganzen staatlichen intervention weil
der staat kann es nachher nicht besser
machen die lösung der krise von wie
schnell produzieren wir masken der markt
wie soll das alles richten können wir
darüber dann nächste woche reden wir
jetzt unsere natürlich wie toll der mann
sie uns durch diese krise ausführen
lauter sie glauben sie dass der glauben
sie der staat er findet jetzt das virus
ist das das anti- dort also das serum
gegen die die impfung nein das hat uns
das wieder ein wenn es nächste woche
darum geht dass nikolaus blome das lob
der
wirtschaft wächst dankeschön der was
denn sonst
[Musik]